you have launched an extremely
successful companies you have helped
others you've invested in companies can
you give advice on how to start
a successful company
I would say have a problem that you
really really really want to solve right
something that you're deeply passionate
about
um
and honestly take the first step like
that's often the hardest
and don't overthink it like you know
like this idea of a minimum viable
product or a minimum viable version of
an idea right like yes you're thinking
about this like a humongous like super
elegant super beautiful thing what like
reduce it to the littlest thing they can
bring to Market that can solve a problem
or that can I you know that can help
um address a pain point that somebody
has
um they often tell you like start with a
customer of one right if you can solve a
problem for one person
then there's probably myself or some
other person right pick a person exactly
it could be you yeah that's actually
often a good sign that if you enjoy a
thing right enjoy a thing you have a
specific problem that you'd like to
solve that's a good that's a good end of
one to to focus on right what else what
else is there to actually so Step One is
the hardest but
there's other steps as well right
um I also think
like who you bring around the table
early on is so key right like being
clear on on what I call like your core
values or your North Star it might sound
fluffy but actually it's not so
and Roz and I feel like we did that very
early on we sat around her kitchen table
and we said okay there's so many
applications of this technology how are
we going to draw the line how are we
going to set boundaries we came up with
a set of core values
that in the hardest of times we fell
back on to determine how we make
decisions and so I feel like just
getting Clarity on these courts like for
us it was respecting people's privacy
only engaging with Industries where it's
clear opt-in so for instance we don't do
any work in security and surveillance
um so things like that just getting we
very big on you know one of our core
values is human connection and empathy
right and that is yes it's an AI company
but it's about people well these are all
they become encoded in how we
act even even if you're a small tiny
team of two or three or whatever
um so I think that's another piece of
advice so what about finding people
hiring people if you care about people
as much as you do like and it's it's it
seems like such a difficult thing to uh
to hire the right people I think early
on as a startup you want people who have
um who share the passion and the
conviction because because it's gonna be
tough like I've yet to meet
a startup where it was just a straight
line to success yeah right even even not
just start up like even in everyday
people's lives right there you always
like how run into obstacles and you run
into naysayers and
um
so you need people who are believers
whether they're people on your team or
even your investors you need investors
who are really Believers in what you're
doing because that means they will stick
with you they won't they won't give up
at the first obstacle yeah
yeah what about raising money what about
finding investors
first of all raising raising money but
also raising money from the right
sources from the ultimately don't hinder
you but help you Empower you all that
kind of stuff what advice would you give
there you successfully raise money and
many times in your life yeah again it's
not just about the money
um it's about writing finding the right
investors who are going
to be aligned in terms of what you want
to build and believe in your core values
like for example
especially later on like I
yeah in my latest like round of funding
I try to bring in investors that really
care about like the ethics of AI right
and they alignment of of
vision and Mission and core values is
really important it's like you're
picking a life partner right
it's the same kind of so you take it
that seriously for investors yeah
because they're gonna have to stick
you're stuck together for a while anyway
yeah
maybe not for life but for a while for
sure yeah better or worse I forget what
the vowels usually sound like For Better
or Worse no they're weird
or something yeah yeah yeah
oh boy
um yeah anyway this it's romantic and
deep and you're in it for a while
um so it's not just about the money
you tweet about going to your first
capital Camp investing get together and
yeah and then you learned a lot so this
is about
um investing so what what have you
learned from that what have you learned
about investing in general
from both because even on both ends of
it
I mean I try to use my experience as an
operator
now with my investor hat on when I'm
identifying companies to to invest in
um first of all I think the good news is
because I have a technology background
right and I really understand you know
machine learning and computer vision and
AI Etc I can apply that level of
understanding right because everybody
says they're an AI company or they're an
AI Tech and I'm like no no no no show me
the technology so I can do that level of
diligence which I actually love
um and then I I have to do the litmus
test of you know if I'm in a
conversation with you am I excited to
tell you about this new company that I
just met right and and and if I
if I'm an ambassador for that company
and I'm passionate about what they're
doing I I usually use that yeah that's
important to me when I'm investing
so that means you actually can explain
what they're doing and and you're
excited about it exactly exactly thank
you for putting it
so succinctly I'm just like rambling but
exactly that's it
sometimes it's funny but sometimes it's
unclear exactly
you I'll hear people tell me you know in
the talk for a while and it's sounds
cool like they paint a picture of a
world but then when you try to summarize
it you're not exactly clear
of what uh maybe maybe with the core
powerful idea is like you can't just
build another Facebook or
um there has to be a
there has to be a core
simple to explain idea that yeah that
then you can or can't get excited about
but this it's there it's something right
there yeah
yeah what uh but like how do you
ultimately
pick who you think would be successful
it's not just about the thing you're
excited about like but there's other
stuff right and
companies which is where I'm investing
sometimes the the business model isn't
clear yet or the go to market strategy
isn't clear there's usually like it's
very early on that some of these things
haven't been hashed out which is okay so
the way I like to think about it is like
if this company is successful will this
be a multi-billion slash trillion dollar
market operative you know or company and
and so that's definitely a lens that I
use
um what's pre was pre-seed what are the
different stages and what's the most
exciting stage and what's or not what's
what's interesting about every stage I
guess yeah so a pre-seed is usually when
you're just starting out you've maybe
raised the friends and family around so
you've raised some money from people you
know and you're getting ready to for to
take your First Institutional check-in
like first check from an investor
and
um
I love this stage there's a lot of
uncertainty so some investors really
don't like this stage because the
financial models aren't there often the
teams aren't even like formed really
really early
um
but to me if
if it's like a magical stage because
it's it's the time when there's so much
conviction so much belief almost
delusional right yeah right and there's
a little bit of naivete around
with with Founders at the stage and I
just love it it's contagious and um I
and I love I love that I can
often they're first-time Founders not
always but often they're first-time
Founders and I can share my experience
as a Founder myself and I can empathize
right and I can almost
I create a safe ground where because you
know you have to be careful what you
tell your investors right
and I will I will often like say I've
been in your shoes as a Founder you can
tell me if it's challenging you can tell
me what you're struggling with it's okay
to vent so I create that safe ground
um and I think I think that's the
superpower
yes you have to uh what I guess you have
to figure out if this kind of person is
going to able to ride the roller coaster
uh like of many pivots and
challenges and all that kind of stuff
and if the space of ideas they're
working in is is interesting like the
way they think about the world yeah
because it
if it's successful the thing they end up
with might be very different the reason
right successful for actually you you
know I was gonna say the third quite so
so the technology is one aspect the
market or the idea right is the second
and the third is the founder right is
this somebody who I believe has
conviction is a hustler you know is
gonna
overcome obstacles
um yeah I think that it is going to be a
great leader right like as a startup as
a Founder you're often you are the first
person and your role is to bring amazing
people around you to build this thing
and so
you're in an evangelist right so how
good are you going to be at that so I
try to evaluate that too
you're also in the Tweet Thread about it
mentioned is this a known concept random
Rich dudes rrds okay and saying that
there should be like random rich women I
guess what's the dudes what's the dude's
version of women the women version of
dudes ladies I don't know I don't know
what's what's is this the technical term
is this known random questions I didn't
make that up but I was at this Capital
Camp which is a get-together for uh
investors of all types and there must
have been maybe 400 or so
attendees
maybe 20 were women it was just very
disproportionately
um you know a male a male dominated
which I'm used to I think you're used to
this kind of thing I'm used to it but
it's still surprising and as I'm raising
money for this fund so my my fund
partner is a guy called Rob May
who's done this before so I'm new to the
investing world but he's done this
before
most of our investors in the fund are
these I mean awesome I'm super grateful
to them random just Rich guys I'm like
where are the rich women so I'm really
adamant in both investing in women-led
AI companies
but I also would love to have women
investors be part of my fund
um because I think that's how we drive
change yeah so the net you know that
that takes time of course but there's
been quite quite a lot of progress but
yeah for for the next Mark Zuckerberg to
be a woman and all that kind of stuff
because that that's just like a huge
number of wealth generated by right by
women and then controlled by women then
allocated by women exactly
and then beyond just women just broadly
across all different measures of
diversity and so on